humans stand alone in the animal kingdom
our power over nature is unparalleled
what separates us what is it that makes
us human
the answer lies in our mastery of
communication the power to express
complex thoughts and ideas to organize
and think collectively these are the
engines of our success driving our
ascent from hunter-gatherers to a global
civilization
communication is everywhere our
technology has propelled us to a new age
of interconnectedness waves of data pass
through us at the speed of light
[Applause]
music language art the written word
through these tools the boundless human
imagination has been given a voice they
give a self expression and collective
knowledge they have a dark side these
tools are so powerful that they distort
our very perception of reality they can
subvert and corrupt and even manipulate
entire population communication is what
makes us how did it emerge how did it
transform us to a creature that could
dream to a creature that could imagine
where millions could eventually learn to
cooperate to overcome to transcend this
is the story of how our world came to be
how communications defined our species
and created the modern age how connected
humanity and sense our voice and a
course for the star this is origin
[Music]